are we all procrastinators oh yeah
absolutely we're we're probably the
biggest progressed inators there is and
and the only reason for that is because
writing is hard
creating is hard yeah I mean I'm
probably the biggest foot press in there
it is we you know every writer will
relate to the experience of you know
trying to do anything else but right you
know the whole thing about sharpening
your pencils and doing your laundry and
cleaning your house and you know
answering emails or playing solitaire
you know on one hand it's something
that's advised because there's that
whole thing about the creative process
where you know we're talking the
gestation period where you're supposed
to think about your problem your
creative problem and then kind of ignore
it and do something else that's
unrelated
that helps creatively so people think
okay that means procrastination you can
do other things and there is some truth
to it the problem is is if you're
constantly afraid to write and so you're
trying to do other things then you'll
never write because you're just
constantly procrastinating so there's
got to be a point where you you've got
to put that aside and actually write so
you got to get over it and it's plenty
I mean online there's tons of advice
about procrastination and how to avoid
it because it's not just for writing
it's for everybody everybody for creston
aids you know anything that's worthwhile
to do and it's scary to do people will
procrastinate I think it's very you said
that fear is more what's at stake not
writer's block that there really isn't
writer's block
there isn't any right please don't
believe that I could be I'm wrong but I
think it's fear it's it's fear of fear
of success fear of failure fear of being
judged negatively fear of being be
embarrassing yourself you know those are
certainly old fears that I relate to and
that you know I have to overcome well
why do you think we put the label of
writer's block on it like I've heard
some people say well you know I'm
currently blocked right now
and it's like it's an affliction cuz it
sounds good I mean I seconds oh well
right lucky for artists I'm a real
artist because I have writer's block or
but block just really means you're not
writing it just means your the words are
not coming up and the reason the words
are not coming up because fear is
creating an attention that prevents you
from from writing you know that's what
it is so you know it's like saying you
know a plumber or plumber doesn't have
plumbers block right this has got to do
their job it's right doing it's about
doing your job showing up at your at
your job you have to understand that
writing is a job well you get paid or
not you got to show up to your desk and
you got to put your butt on the chair
and you got it type words you know so
that's what it is and so we used as an
excuse we say well it really is fear of
writing fear of whatever all those
procrastinating things I've said but it
doesn't sound to say oh I'm afraid it
sounds a lot better to say I'm blocked
because then people can go oh poor you
oh yeah you're you're an artist you know
so it sounds better but it's really it's
just fear you know and again there's
plenty of material out there about how
to overcome those fears so it's all
psychological stuff you just have to
overcome do you see a lot of that fear
resurface once someone's really gone out
there and either pitched or shared their
material material excuse me or had you
know quote people in their peer group
given feedback yes and it's usually
because you know the writing they didn't
respond to the writing as much as they
wanted to they've really expected the
pat on the back and being told how great
it was and chances are it wasn't as good
so really it's up to you it depends on
how thick your skin is it's about how
much you want this and how much you were
conscious enough to understand that
feedback is important and that you
should take it as it is you should look
at as constructive criticism and and pay
attention to it and rewrite and make it
better it's all about making it better
and you really got to know how to do it
it's big part of the Hollywood job you
know as a screenwriter you
you know I've never heard of something
being just first draft you know it's
always draft I mean you know 30 drafts
40 drafts you know so it's constantly
and you got to be able to do that if
you're the type of writer who does not
like to be told that something is wrong
and wants to say no this is the way it
is it's my art and that's what it is you
shouldn't be writing screenplays you
should be writing novels or plays that's
really the only two professions where
the writer is King really unless you're
doing television this television the
writer is King there but but mostly
novelists and playwrights where yeah the
editor can tell you something that's not
working and you could take it or leave
it but it's really you you have the
final say on it then you should do that
but you know I think people who have
think skins or are very sensitive about
creative feedback should not be
screenwriters
I mean they're in for a really you know
very frustrating experience if that's
the case
you